Ein Marketingprofi im Auftrag
einer Shoppingstadt.
Hier bekommt jedes Einkaufsevent
seinen eigenen Namen.
Das ist eine
„Golden Week Shopping Special“,
die andere ist „Luna New Year
Shopping Special“.
Das haben wir organisiert nur
für unsere chinesische[n] Kunde[n].
Ihr Job:
Noch mehr chinesische Kunden
ins süddeutsche Metzingen holen.
Diese Gruppe ist auf Einkaufstour.
In Berlin, Prag und Wien
war sie schon,
jetzt ist Einkaufen angesagt.
Ich war schon gestern Abend hier.
Wir haben anderthalb Tage.
Heute will ich bis 20 Uhr bleiben.
Rund 500.000 Chinesen kommen
jedes Jahr nach Metzingen –
von rund vier Millionen
Besuchern insgesamt.
Über die „Outletcity“ haben sie sich
schon in Shanghai informiert.
Sie wollen die Labelstores
mit den Luxusmarken.
Touristen aus aller Welt –
die Einzelhändler hier lernen alles
über ihren Geschmack
und ihre Mentalität.
Und sie stellen Verkaufspersonal ein,
das die richtigen Sprachen spricht.
Für Tourismus-Managerin Wu aber
waren die letzten Monate nicht leicht.
Sie soll mehr Chinesen
in die Einkaufsstadt bringen,
doch die machen sich Sorgen wegen der
Terroranschläge in Deutschland und Europa.
Manche schrecken vor der Reise zurück.
Meine Rolle ist eher,
[dass ich] die richtige Information
über Deutschland zu berichten.
Genau.
Und wir haben auch …
also, wir haben nicht gesagt:
Okay, wir verzichten jetzt [auf den]
chinesischen Markt wegen Terror,
sondern wir haben mehr …
also, ich war mehr in China
und ich hab auch mehr
den Kunden gesagt:
Wir sind ganz normal hier,
und wir leben auch ganz normal hier,
und sie können immer noch mehr,
also häufiger kommen.
Viele Produkte sind in Europa billiger
als zuhause in China,
denn da droht die Luxussteuer.
Wer zum Shoppen kommt,
hat oft eine lange Einkaufsliste –
die Verwandtschaft ist online
und mit konkreten Bestellungen dabei.
Die haben extrem viel Geld.
Also, die geben echt viel aus.
Also, die kaufen sehr viel.
Aber von der Zeit –
die sind sehr, sehr
unter Druck sozusagen.
Weil die kommen nur für kurze Zeit,
also für zehn, fünfzehn Minuten,
die kaufen echt viel ein,
und dann gehen sie wieder.
Powershopping auch bei diesem Paar:
ein Anzug für 1.000 Euro
und einen Koffer gleich dazu.
Lieblingsmarke: Hugo Boss.
Der deutsche Herrenausstatter
war der erste Fabrikshop in Metzingen.
Nun soll der Outletstore weiter wachsen
zum größten „Boss-Shop“ der Welt.
Fehlt noch: Alipay.
Frau Wu will die Geschäfte
überzeugen, technisch aufzurüsten.
Denn chinesische Kunden, sagt sie,
zahlen in ihrer Heimat
längst mobil mit ihrem Handy.
Ich glaube, Deutschland
ist wirklich sehr rückständig
bezüglich internationaler
Zahlungsmodalität, ja.
Also, es ist nicht so üblich,
[dass man] wirklich mit dem Handy
in Deutschland etwas zu bezahlen, ja.
Dieses Geschäft hat sich schon
entschlossen, technisch aufzurüsten.
Die chinesischen Kunden sehen
das als Wertschätzung.
Sie sind überrascht, dass wir das,
die Zahlungsfunktion, auch haben,
und nutzen es sofort.
Liping Shen ist in Eile.
Halbzeit ihrer Shoppingtour.
Sie hat edle Küchenmesser
eines deutschen Herstellers gekauft.
Dazu einen Gürtel für ihren Mann.
Der allein kostete 140 Euro.
Das sind europäische Marken.
Die Sachen wurden auch
in Europa produziert.
Und hier sind sie
preiswerter als zu Hause.
Nach drei Stunden hat sie
für rund 600 Euro eingekauft.
Wie hoch ihr Budget
insgesamt ist, sagt sie nicht,
nur so viel:
Sie kauft, was ihr gefällt.